There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
I'm a lip-oil freak,
so I was dying to try out
these NYX Fat Oil Lip Drips.
I bought so many.
They have the huge doe-foot
applicator that I love
and a very subtle fruity scent.
This isn't a perfect dupe
for the Dior lip oil.
The formula is slightly thinner,
and the brush doesn't pick up
and apply the product as smoothly,
but these definitely have
more of a color payoff.
I do think this is the best lip oil
I've tried from the drugstore for sure.
It feels so comfortable
and hydrating on the lips,
and I love the range of colors they have.
I haven't tried a powder
foundation in a minute.
This is the Maybelline Super Stay
hybrid powder-foundation.
I just used the little sponge
that came with the powder to apply it
all over my already
moisturized and primed face.
This powder is meant to give
medium to full coverage.
I feel like it's more full coverage,
but it doesn't look cakey to me.
I didn't even use concealer with this
because I felt like the
coverage it gave me was enough.
I noticed that it did exaggerate
the dryness around my nose a bit,
but some setting spray helped
it all melt into the skin
and not look so dry.
My other products blended
on top of this just fine,
and it feels super weightless on the skin,
and I noticed that I wasn't as oily
at the end of the day.
About-face released these
Cherry Pick lip color butters,
and I am in love with these.
This kind of lipstick formula
is so popular right now,
but this one is 100% my favorite.
They apply like butter,
as the name suggests.
Just so creamy and moisturizing.
It feels like a slippy lip balm,
but you still get a
really nice color payoff,
and they kind of smell like peaches to me,
but not in a gross, super-artificial way.
I highly recommend these.
This is the Half Magic Cheek Fluff.
I love that name because
it describes this formula perfectly.
It's this supersoft,
fluffy, putty-like blush
that is so buildable.
I genuinely think this blush is foolproof.
Like, you can't apply too much.
I'm typically very
heavy-handed with my makeup,
but this applied like
a soft flush of color.
It looks kind of blurring on the cheeks,
which I really liked.
It also comes in this compostable
and recyclable packaging,
which is so great to see.
We have another transfer-proof
lipstick to test out.
This is the Revlon ColorStay
Suede Ink lipstick.
This really does feel
like suede on the lips.
It's a very soft and
comfortable matte finish
that doesn't feel drying at all.
For the most part
they had really good color payoff,
except this brighter red-orange.
This one was actually pretty patchy,
so just a warning in case
you were interested in
the brighter shades.
I did a little kiss test on my hand,
and they actually are transfer-proof.
This is my first time ever
trying Oden's Eye cosmetics.
They released these
Jewel Shine eyeshadows,
and I had to test them out.
Ignore that blue shade. It came damaged,
but I still wanted to swatch it anyway.
There are two formulas with these,
the multichromes and the shimmers.
The multichromes are more expensive.
These formulas are just so buttery smooth.
They have beautiful glitter in them
that doesn't feel chunky,
and it doesn't give
you fallout everywhere.
They look so pretty
and shifty on the eyes,
and they have, like, a billion colors.
It was so hard to choose.
I really enjoyed using these,
and I want to try more Oden's
Eye products in the future.
This product caught my eye one day
when I was just scrolling through Ulta.
This is the Pacifica Kind Glaze
Dewy Glow Layer face primer.
That name reeled me in,
and I just had to try it.
I was kind of expecting
it to be clear and oily,
but it's more like a creamy,
slightly pigmented gel.
It does add a really
natural glow to the skin.
Like, it's not metallic-looking.
I used my go-to foundation on top,
and I think this is a really nice primer.
My foundation looked really smooth,
and I could see that subtle
glow peeking through.
16 bucks is a lot for the drugstore,
but I really liked this.
This is the Sacheu
Beauty lip liner Stay-N.
It's a peel-off lip liner
that leaves a stain behind.
This is so much like
that peel-off lipstick
I tested a while back.
You have to leave this on for 20 minutes,
which I thought was a little nuts.
That's so much time.
The first time I did it,
the stain was just kind of noticeable.
I used the nude shade,
but it looked way more pink than nude.
I did it again to see if I
could make it more pigmented,
and it kind of worked.
I could definitely see it more,
but I feel like it just looked patchy.
I do have a pigmented lip line,
so maybe that's why it's
not looking great on me.
I feel like this is a good idea
but not a great execution.
Haus Labs just released
this Color Fuse blush.
These colors are just delicious.
I'm so in love with them.
The Haus Labs powder formulas
are some of the best I've ever tried.
This literally just melts into the skin.
It looks so smooth on the cheeks,
and you can build up
the color really easily.
Like, you can make these look as vibrant
as they look in the pan.
These are pricey,
but I think a talc-free
formula this good is worth it.
This is the MAC lash dry
shampoo mascara refresher,
and it's supposed to soften
your existing mascara
so your mascara is
refreshed but not clumpy.
I don't know if that made any sense,
but let's talk about it.
So, the first time I tried it,
I applied it over my mascara
that was a few hours old,
and it wasn't softening
the mascara at all.
Then I realized this can't be
used over waterproof mascara.
So I tried it again
over my regular mascara,
and it worked so much better.
This is one of those
products though that's, like,
yeah, it works, but at the same time,
do I really need this? Probably not.
Danessa Myricks released
these Yummy skin-blurring
balm powder flushed blushes.
I think this is the same formula
as the balm powder, just in blush form.
These are so pigmented,
but in the you-need-to-be-careful
kind of way.
Apply too much, and you will regret it.
My preferred way to apply
was to warm some up on the back of my hand
and slowly build it up with a brush
so I have more control.
These are really smooth and blurring.
They have this kind of soft-matte finish
that looks really pretty.
Alissa Ashley influenced me to buy
the Sephora Microsmooth
face powder years ago,
and I stopped using it for some reason,
but I don't know why,
because this is an amazing product.
It is the smoothest, silkiest powder
that you can do so much with.
It's described as a powder foundation,
but you can also use this to set makeup,
to bronze, or to highlight.
I just used this as an
all-over finishing powder,
and it immediately gives
you this soft-focus finish.
It applies so beautifully
without making your
skin look cakey and dry.
I am definitely obsessed
with this once again.
This is the KVD Good Apple full-coverage
transfer-proof serum foundation.
I have to address this immediately:
This is, like, four shades
too light for me, but we move.
I still wanted to test the formula.
This has pretty full coverage,
but not to the point
where it looks unnatural,
if that makes sense.
It dried down very quickly
and had a more matte finish
than I was expecting with
the word "serum" in the name.
It looked OK over my more textured areas.
It didn't look cakey,
and it felt lightweight on my skin.
It's a very OK foundation.
Didn't love it, didn't hate it,
I just know that $42 is a lot for it.
ColourPop released these
adorable highlighters
that I had to purchase because ... hearts.
These are more subtle
than I was expecting.
I did have to build them up a bit,
but they didn't get chunky
or too metallic-looking.
They build up really nicely.
I was mostly excited to
try out this lavender one
because I never wear color highlighter.
The purply color was pretty obvious,
but it actually looked so cute.
This is the Wet n Wild
5-in-1 essence primer liquid.
So you shake this really well,
then apply it to the face.
You have to let it sit for a minute
before you apply your makeup.
I actually think this gave
me a really nice base.
My skin looked a bit
smoother, it looked glowy,
and it had a slight tackiness to it.
I tend to like a tacky primer.
All of my makeup applied
really well on top of this,
and I didn't get oilier than
normal throughout the day.
This has a lot of mixed reviews,
but I liked this primer.
These are the Charlotte Tilbury
matte beauty blush wands.
People have been using her
highlighter wands as blush,
but this is the first actual blush wand.
These have amazing color payoff.
A little goes a really long way,
but you want to move fast with these.
They do dry down a bit quickly.
But these are so pretty,
and they blend out really
well over other products.
I love these.
Another day, another
glossy lipstick to try out.
This is the Flower Beauty
plump up gloss stick.
The formula is thinner
than I was expecting,
just based on other similar
lip products I've tried.
It doesn't really plump much.
You just get a slight tingling feeling.
This feels so nice and
hydrating on the lips,
but it's more like a lip
balm than a lip gloss.